over a hundred business people leading
some of Britain's best known companies
have spoken out their message couldn't
be clearer the conservative long-term
economic plan is right it's working and
the label alternative would risk the
recovery and risk job loss I felt that
it's the kind of thing you expect in a
general election do we succeed with a
few corporations and individuals doing
well or do we succeed where working
people succeed at that's my view and I
think that's a view of the British
people at work he doesn't seem too
nervous I'm going out that it's human
soon thank you I'm absolutely sir Nick
Clegg will win you see I have no
intention of bowing out I have every
intention and certainly every confidence
but I will wear for EU funding a
publicity material that's got into
school so it certainly designed to catch
people young and feed them propaganda
only thing that people you should be
scared is the new key partners to
continue before the stage of program
difference no violence and run
what we put on the end of the mound I
went to straight ass going to me and I
said did you do the same and they said
no we had to lie down to recover